[Music]
when does probation end and does
probation end earlier for god's people
what happens when probation closes
no one knows friend probation ends
there's no date the only the last date
we had was october 22 1844 we have no
date for the closing probation and god
knows why he didn't give us a deal
people try to i'll wait two days before
the date comes and i'll get myself right
with god there are people like that i'll
confess on my deathbed there's no date
for the closer probation now but let me
tell you this if you die tonight your
probation has closed and so today is the
date for your probation personal life
you say today is the final day of my
probation because i may not see you
tomorrow now as far as um what's the
second part of the question
second part of the question was does
probation end earlier okay yes yes yes
now first peter chapter 4 verse 17 said
for the time is come that judgment must
begin at the house of god now
now that judgment does not just cover
advocates it covers all those who've
ever professed a relationship with
christ you see now he's going to judge
your profession by your works you see
you said you love me you said you've
given your life you said you obey me you
took all these baptismal vows let me now
examine how you live that's why we saved
my words we saved by faith but we're
judged by words and so this judgment
began in october 22 1844 it's a judgment
of those who've had a relationship
profess a relationship with jesus christ
so in that sense yes it begins with the
house of god according to first peter 4
17. so you can say yes it ends for
advertise first because we're all part
of that group who have professed a
relationship with god now when that
judgment ends there isn't another one
because the wicked has already condemned
themselves by rejecting christ are you
following me the wicked have already
condemned themselves by rejecting christ
so there is no need for judgment of them
as to whether they are saved or lost
they have chosen to be lost by rejecting
christ the judgment for the wicked is
the degree of punishment they'll receive
and we will join christ in doing that
during the thousand years but yes
judgment begins at the house of god and
the house of god is not just advocates
the house of god is other sheep of i
which are not of this fault them also i
must bring so it begins in the house of
god and when that judgment that
pre-advert judgment used to be called
investigative judgment ends probation
has ended there is no further judgment
to decide will be saved or who will be
lost
amen
you